it is time for this week's pet project
lori herron joins us from the nspca and
she brought along someone who needs a
safe
and good home got a beautiful cat there
lori
yes i do this beautiful orange tabby boy
his name is
noodle and he is um herring right now
he's really a love box
he is just a little older than a kitten
here
and he is healthy he has a very mild
case of
a condition called stomatitis kendall
which can easily be treated and we can
tell you more about that
he has a lot of energy he's a little
mischievous
and he tends to dominate so we don't
know if he'd get along with
every cat so you would have to talk to
us more about that because
um noodle can sometimes have too much
energy for
other cats in the home as always people
can come visit noodle and other pets
there before they actually adopt
and you say this is something i wasn't
aware of kitten season or at least it's
just around the corner
it is so kitten season which is another
name for feline breeding season
which happens when the weather starts
getting warmer
has already started and nevada spca
is getting ready for the kittens in a
lot of ways and
one of the ways is that tomorrow night
we are featuring an exclusive webinar
with
the kitten lady who is one of the
foremost experts on taking care of stray
kittens and saving their lives
and if you go to nevadaspca.org you can
register for this free
webinar with the kitten lady it's two
hours you can do it from the comfort of
your own pouch in your pajamas and watch
the kitten lady and learn about what
you can do if you find kittens on the
streets in southern nevada which happens
to many of us during kitten season well
apparently it's a big problem in and
around las vegas right
there are so many cats on the streets
here and there are so many great groups
out there
like um i'll shout out to c5 who
devote their lives to trapping these
cats and
and sterilizing them so that we can stop
um the number of homeless cats that are
on the streets
but it's a real problem in southern
nevada and one that we want to stay
ahead of
and again if you find the kittens um we
go to if you watch the webinar tomorrow
night you can learn more about what to
do
if you find those um straight kittens on
the street so that we can save their
lives
all right lori good information as
always if you're interested
in adopting a pet you can go or in that
workshop tomorrow night you can go to
nevadaspca.org
or you can call them at that phone
number 702-873-7722
rocky